[Applause]
you had a hot take about
c spiricy that i refused to let you tell
me
um you said that there were some flaws
in c-spirits we're obviously talking
about the netflix uh
documentary about how we got to stop
eating fish
um ben is half japanese
so he's mostly made out of fish and
uh you thought that the documentary had
a lot of good things because you're
someone cares about sustainability
but you thought there were some holes
so it's so funny that uh
documentaries have i think they've taken
on almost too much importance for
sort of information gathering because uh
what i really like about documentaries
is that you get a very
distinct point of view but they're
presented as if it is
the way it is right and i and i i think
that's the thing
it's not to like look uh with
trepidation at documentaries
is just to consider the way they were
made and what i love about documentaries
is the handcrafted approach
clearly that was the work of years and
years about a very passionate
diligent hard-working person and he
should be celebrated for that
and i think it's a fantastic piece of
content that does way more good than it
does harm
but there's limitations because it's
when you're produced from a singular
vision
you don't have the diversity of sort of
fact checking that you do with more sort
of
traditional and mainstream what did he
get wrong i'd also like to say that we
went out to a delicious sushi restaurant
last night uchi out here in miami is
amazing what did he get wrong he said
that like sustainable fishing is
impossible
and i could i would totally be fine if
he switched that too
like it's going to be really really hard
and we should be really skeptical about
anyone making claims about the
sustainability of a particular fishing
initiative
yeah but i think it's often uh
overstatement is a
part of deception that i think is
particularly damaging yeah
saying that something is impossible is
such an arrogant claim
how do you know yeah yeah who the [ __ ]
are you there's so many things that we
thought weren't possible
the later we're proved not to be just
cause you can't figure out how to do it
doesn't mean it's impossible it's like
saying that consumers will never
really want electric cars and it looked
that way it did look
highly probable and people doing like
deep research into consumer trends
20 years ago it would be fair for them
to come to that very reasonable
conclusion that it's unlikely that
electric cars will ever be
as desirable if not more desirable than
gas cars
except for like the most hardcore
environmental nuts that
that improbability has happened and
when you say if you said that was
impossible you're 100 wrong if you said
it was improbable you're mostly right
yeah so i have a big problem with those
kind of overstatements
if you want to see a really good fact
checking uh shout out to my buddy
uh jack and finn harry's they're these
twins they do really
they're actually what greta thundberg
should be yeah um
they're environmental activists they're
kind of the good ones they actually do
the work
she's the jake paul with a good cause
yeah yeah she's jake paul of
environmentalism yeah and it's like it's
i think she's a net positive overall
yeah let me explain why this is so good
because uh
like is she is jake the best boxer
no is he eating up all the oxygen in
boxing
taking it away from people that are
actually put way more years into the
craft
is that his fault no not at all it
matter of fact he's bringing way more
awareness to the sport of boxing
and there's a bunch of boxers that are
going to make a lot of money just
because
new eyeballs are on boxing right now
greta
doesn't know [ __ ] about the environment
compared to these people who have
dedicated their lives to it she's no
[ __ ] scientist right
she's a 14 year old swedish girl who
might have a little bit of uh
autism it's not for me to say but
it will be for me to say i will say it
yeah she's got a little bit of tissue
autism she's got a little tiss
yeah she's test i think she's a i think
she's a net positive i think she's done
great things i think it's important to
mobilize that generation and i think the
fundamental idea that like
old people are mortgaging her future is
not invalid
but what bothers me is that you see
people that have spent 30 years sort of
working it's the same way you've seen
boxers that are actually really good at
their craft yeah
and you know maybe it's their own fault
for not being better at self-promotion
yes that's but it's not unalarming to
see someone that's kind of new to a
space
sort of rise to some sort of prominence
and it's not a complete zero-sum game
like it's not as simple as like this
person gets attention so that this
person can't get attention
that's a little bit of a fallacy yeah
but i think there are
there is some resentment by some
researchers i know in that community
it's like man
i've been really trying to get my stuff
published i've been working on this for
a really long time there's a lot of
people that have
really they're sailing around this
swedish chick the bill mckibbens
michael mcdonald and like all these
people that have actually
done a lifetime of book writing and
research and yeah
and gone to uh gone to conferences where
there's like 30 people
and still gave like a good performance
and
i think it can be a little bit
disheartening for them to see a uh
a child rise ahead but at the same time
like she she created it wasn't handed to
her
yeah and everything's sort of a
combination to a certain degree of kind
of luck
opportunism strategy skill all those
things yeah and also just check your ego
like if you guys have
you know joint interest just because
you're not the one shouting it out to
the world and getting the credit for it
doesn't mean it's not getting done
this is where people got to see what
they really want do they want change in
the world do they want people to care
about the environment or do they want to
be famous because they love the
environment yeah
do you want to be a celebrity or do you
want to make change right but that's
conspiracy so check out uh jack and finn
harry's they've done some sort of things
where they sort of like
sort of went through and sort of fact
checked it uh they have an organization
called earthrise which is trying really
hard it's sort of a young
sort of contemporary media company
that's trying to sort of make these
issues sort of known
right and i think that's what's really
good about our current media landscape
is that somebody throws something out
there
yeah and it's not about saying it's
debunking it
or attacking it yeah it's all augmenting
it if you sort of even point out hey i
think you were a little wrong on this
yeah i think this part was really good
yep
and it doesn't have to be this sort of
flame war of tearing down
or standing for something un
uncritically yeah it can just be like
kind of a little wrong on the fishing
thing
so the sea spirit of sea thing is
interesting because uh one of the claims
is we got to stop eating fish and
if we don't stop eating fish there's
going to be no fish left and if there's
no fish left we're gonna ruin our oceans
if we ruin our oceans there's no more
oxygen we all die
this is the environmentalist approach
towards everything is 50 years we're all
dead no matter what we do
uh but one thing i really liked about it
and the way they got us into it which i
think was brilliant
is uh they gave us our plastic straws
back right
and i really think that that was a
strategic move right they basically said
in the documentary the guy says that
plastic straws make up .003
of ocean pollution all the ocean
pollution is really from these fishing
uh vessels these commercial fishing
vessels that have these huge nets they
just leave the nets in the water there's
all this
what is called by byproduct or something
like that by waste or whatever it is
they're just leaving the stuff all over
the ocean it's really [ __ ] up coral
reefs
and um when i when i saw that i was like
yeah it's on the fisherman it's not on
me
i get my straws back my life is is now
fixed
right okay holes
no i think that's actually what it
pointed out
was we look for things that hit us
emotionally and that tie into a
intellectual understanding of a problem
but not necessarily the problem at the
appropriate scale
yeah so we saw that one video of like a
straw stuck in a turtle's nose yeah
and i felt really bad for that turtle
and it did make me feel
a very empathetic way and be like well
if i if i would have saw in that turtle
right there i definitely wouldn't have
used the straw i would use the shitty
paper one
yeah but the problem is is that's not
really
actually any in that turtle as noble as
it is and as much as we would like to
save it
isn't necessarily an indication of
environmental problems at scale
it's still an indicator it's not fake
it's just not necessarily
it's not showing the whole story of
where we're actually polluting yes
so plastics in general are a really big
problem yeah it's this thing that we
that we produce a lot of straws are a
very small part of the plastics we do
the styrofoam from all these amazon
packaging is way
more problematic than that plastic bags
all these things so
it's funny i've been doing a lot of sort
of experimental recycling
projects yeah and it sort of sounds nice
like ah
recycling stuff is good for an
environment it's actually like
it's not accomplishing that much but it
also doesn't make it unimportant not to
do
yeah like it's not that like trying to
save straws is a bad thing we sh
we shouldn't use straws but it's not the
thing that we should be focused on the
most
so if somebody like volunteers like hey
i don't want to use straws great
but if you're getting to the point where
you're then indicting someone else for
using something that's actually a pretty
small part of the problem
meanwhile you have like you know eight
cubic yards of styrofoam sitting at your
house from amazon packages that you
ordered
yeah you're not really doing any good
yeah so
it's really just like putting when a
problem's at scale you should attack
the biggest scale of the problem first
not focusing on the detail
that has the heart-wrenching turtle
video attached to it well i thought
that's what the
the documentary exposed right right it's
like we can't
attack the problem because there are
forces that be that don't want us to
attack
if the problem is commercial fishing and
there's a lot of money behind commercial
fishing
that money is going to point us in the
direction of straws because straws don't
affect commercial fishing's bottom line
at all
so i i'm in a weird position in the sort
of sustainable community like i care a
lot about it i think it's one of the
most important things we can do but i'm
also not too worried about it because i
think collectively humanity is kind of
like how most of us were in college that
we
kind of procrastinate and procrastinate
but we mostly get it done at the last
minute
and so i don't want to fall into that
kind of thing like fishing will be fine
we'll figure it out
because we might not and we'll probably
lose some species that we really like
eating right now and eventually
they will lose something we probably
won't lose everything
and what happens is is fishing
uh will continue to or fish supplies
will continue to be diminished yeah
it'll become more and more expensive at
sushi restaurants like we went to last
night
and then more it'll be more economically
viable for people to invest in figuring
out the next generation of fish farming
so it's like right now we farm salmon
it's not great salmon
yeah but if there was more capital going
into it because the price of salmon is
better it's that would be better
that being said there's going to be
other downsides to that
you know it is sustainability and
environmentalism it's not this thing
that can ever be solved it's like the
marvel cinematic universe
you'll beat thanos they'll be a new bad
guy because there has to be more content
and we have to keep watching and we have
to keep doing it
and it's exactly why i really like this
cause as something to sort of tie
it's not like my main focus in my career
but it's something i always keep
touching back into and seeing if i can
do a little bit of progress in this
arena
because we'll never solve it and that
shouldn't be the frustrating thing that
should be the exciting thing
it's a job for life because imagine if
you like dedicated your life to like
a career and just as you were starting
to get good somebody else solved it
and you're just like well [ __ ] i always
say this about uh
i was uh say this to whitney i'm like
the reason that you want to save animals
is because you'll never finish doing it
yeah for the rest of your life you will
have something to do you'll just make
more animals from all those animals that
you saved
exactly yeah and there's going to be
another animal that's about to go
extinct and you'll want to go say that
always be another hair color too that's
true
yeah and we're ready for it whitney yeah
bring it red
i think she's got to go full red i want
to see full red
okay um i thought that like
the the documentary inadvertently
brought up an interesting conversation
which was like
if you apply the capitalistic mindset
towards a problem
usually it will get solved that there's
enough profit to go with it and i think
that's what happened with straws is like
the second we saw the straw coming out
the turtle's nose yeah we were like
oh we need a different type of straw and
within months
there were 30 different straws that were
like plastic
some of them were were paper but
something
kind of felt plastic enough where you
could drink out of them and they
wouldn't like fold and
bend and break and there's a million
different solutions this problem so
when i'm watching this documentary i'm
like yo why the [ __ ] don't we just be
honest about what the biggest
issue is so we can find a convenient way
to solve it so
i actually think that the the challenge
with recycling in particular
is that is the point of collection so
you know like some states they'll be
like a five
cent deposit when you buy aluminum cans
yeah and then if you turn it to the
store you get that five cent back
all we have to do is just raise that and
we'll return the straws we won't throw
them away
it says there's there's some point where
[ __ ]
there's some point if we said like so
let's say you go and i think they should
do this at bars because like people are
if you're paying 12 for a drink right
like
you're already paying way more than what
the alcohol is worth you're paying for
that lifestyle experience and that
ambiance and that scene and setting
so it's a if they just said like hey the
straw is a dollar
and you get the dollar back if you
return the straw and we put it through
the dishwasher
done that's interesting either people
won't care
and then the homeless people go and pick
up the straws and return them or you
know somebody else will do it because
it's economically incentivized
to do it so we've done things like that
before with like aluminum cans if you're
in like
remember growing up in california they
didn't have that you would see more cans
and trash cans and then you go up to
oregon and it's five cents a can you
would see less cans and trash cans i
remember the first time i went to europe
i i was uh
we stopped off in germany in the airport
right we can use
capitalism we don't have to wait for it
yeah that had
like five different portals there was
one
for cans one for paper one i've never
seen this in my life
and this was their i guess i guess you
know first attempted to getting into
recycling etc
i was like okay yeah this kind of makes
sense but that thing with the straw
makes sense but for me more it's like
what do we do with commercial fishing
like why don't we find a more convenient
uh not sorry less convenient but more
environmentally friendly way to do that
that doesn't tear up the coral reefs
that doesn't like get all the turtles
stuck in the nets
that doesn't where you don't have to go
out there and like i guess
call the dolphins in order to catch
these fish because they're eating them
as well
like why isn't that the problem we're
solving not the [ __ ] straws
because that's a hard problem to solve
well let's go [ __ ] solve it
figure it out we can get to the moon
there i guarantee there's people working
like
at every university just people studying
all sorts of things and they might be
studying from different angles there
might be people
in like sort of a ocean agricultural
program that are studying the future of
seasteading
and uh agricultural production at sea
yeah
and they're looking at the sort of
papers that have been done on early
studies and they're testing out or going
and visiting sort of early fish farming
experiments and they're learning from
that and they're getting better
but there's i think the thing that
surprised me
is so i used to be part of the faculty
at some different universities
yeah and when you're there you sort of
think like oh there's so many people
doing research
yeah but it's not the most focused
research it's research to sort of
elevate yourself within this sort of
academic environment yeah
and then you'll interface with like
people with like major you know pretty
good size companies companies are doing
close to a billion dollars a year
in sales and you look at how big their
research team is and you sort of have
this
vision that it's like a whole floor of
like people like lab coats like looking
through
uh microscopes and like stuff doing
science experiments
yeah yeah it's not there's like billion
dollar companies that maybe have like
three people doing research hilarious
and even like companies like nike it's
not like they have
thousands of engineers doing research
right right
because each one of those people has a
few hundred thousand dollars a year it's
a few things
and it's hard to predict when they're
going to innovate with research so it's
like
there's actually not that much money in
these kind of things
um so there's not like thousands and
thousands of people
studying these things there's a bunch of
people trying to make a living
they're progressing the ball a little
bit forward with a very
limited and compromised agenda towards
where they're getting paid
everyone has the biases of their
industry if you're in academia you're
biased towards making sort of
clean data that's presentable within the
arbitrary limits of your vertical
or your field yeah and if you're working
for a fishing company
it's really about sort of production and
if you have some nice sort of
environmental or sustainable byproducts
from that
that'll be a great marketing push that
we feel better about yeah
so it's like you know you weirdly need
legislation to create financial
incentive
in research like if the legislation
comes out and says straws are illegal
oh there's gonna be some financial
incentive to make a new [ __ ] straw
right because we're gonna want to drink
out of something and a company is going
to step up and fill that void
but if you don't get uniform legislation
you're basically just hurting the
american fishermen or the european
fishermen
and then helping out the fishermen
anywhere else in the world that refuse
to have any legislation
here's the challenge with the
legislation thing and i don't like being
like anti-legislation or pro-legislation
is i think that we have to have a trial
run for these types of legislations
to see if they work because we're set in
the middle there's a lot of unintended
consequences and you're not an idiot if
you don't predict
every eventuality from something as
complex as an ecological system that has
to interface with a legal system
that's hard and complicated yeah so what
we should do with the straws is being
like
okay we all agree that the goal of less
straws in the ocean would be nice
yeah we also think that it's actually
proportionately it's only this part much
of the problem
yeah so let's try this for one year if
we see a reduction in this draws
the law continues if it doesn't we get
rid of it it goes
back to the way it was and we that way
there's an automatic provision for that
what's problematic is when we keep
stacking things that didn't work on top
of each other
and then to get anything launched as a
new product or a building or something
like that
there's all this bureaucracy and stuff
that you have to go through which is all
fine if it's all
effective but we should just have like a
trial period for these types of
regulations so we should say
hey let's try a one dollar deposit on
straws and plastic bags
let's see if that keeps them from
floating around parking lots and oceans
i like that not only for environmentally
friendly legislation but like we could
do that with
cops why don't we do it with everything
this idea that like
you have a trial period for any change
and then you just share data like for
example if you have
what is it called the you know cop cams
what were they called
oh the body cams yeah if you have body
cams on every cop right
you keep them on and if we find out 12
months later there was a 20
reduction in police shootings not just
black people it was just in general
right
without any reduction in the amount of
uh
you know uh people who had warrants out
for their arrests or whatever assault
right
we need to put these things in beta so
you remember how like everyday
what's the beta version of this 100 so
that that's the clever things that
remember like but just if there's a
point but like i guess what i'm trying
to say is if we came back and shared the
data like yo there was this reduction
for this change and then cops come back
and go like yeah first it was kind of
annoying but didn't really change the
way i police and if 20
less people are getting shot by us that
makes us look better and then if after a
year the opposite happened like
there was an increase we could go hey
the body cams aren't the issue let's
throw it out
but we try to make these declarations
and make these like chisel them in stone
and of course you're gonna have all this
pushback because they're in a wiggle
room i
i think the most empowering thing a
leader could do
is just say they don't know about things
they clearly can't know
so uh i really like that did you read
that adam grant book the think again he
sent it i didn't read it yeah
yeah good book i'll tell you about it
later
sorry adam thank you though so he talked
about it's not necessarily how quick you
are to come up with an answer
it's often how quick you are to change
your answer when your answer is clearly
wrong
yeah so he brings up the example of like
steve
jobs versus the blackberry guy remember
blackberries blackberries were kind of
lit for a bit obama refused to get rid
of the blackberry
right and it's like the guy that created
the blackberry was an engineer
really smart he was much more on the
actual inventor side he
figured all these things had a bunch of
patents to his name yeah he was really
into weeds technologically
he thought that everything his early
success in creating this popular device
made him too married to the beliefs
about the sort of
what made the device successful whereas
steve jobs always said i'm not going to
do a phone
i'm not going to do a phones phones are
stupid i don't want to do a phone don't
want to do a phone
he let himself be convinced by his
younger employees
that phones were going to be this really
important thing in the future
so it wasn't that steve jobs always had
the vision right
he was willing to be wrong and change
and i think the same things with that if
you
if we ask our politicians hey always be
right
never flip flop never change your mind
then we get
exactly the political climate and world
we deserve
if we encourage the people to be like
this is a really complex challenging
issue
i want to try this we're going to try it
for this period of time
if this happens we'll keep doing it if
this doesn't happen yeah
i was wrong and we'll move on and try
the next thing at this really big
problem that we all agree is important
this seems like a no-brainer
i mean it seems like a no-brainer i'm
shocked that we don't do this already
it's hard to be wrong publicly it really
is